die wahl zum us-präsidenten wird vor
gericht entschieden für viele keine
überraschung mit so einem guten ergebnis
von donald trump hatten allerdings die
wenigsten gerechnet
er ist ein gewinner dieser wahl selbst
wenn er am ende nicht präsident bleibt
verloren haben die vereinigten staaten
von amerika denn auch ein präsident joe
biden würde die tiefe spaltung des
landes nicht so schnell heilen können
wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
benjamin wolf meyer der sprecher der
republic ins overseas in deutschland
sagt krams entscheidung die gerichte
anzurufen ist richtig
david wird vom german marshall fund sagt
dagegen das ist unfassbar in einer
demokratie
john bolton war sicherheitsberater von
donald trump und weiß er sieht nur seine
eigenen interessen
martin richenhagen für den deutsch
amerikanischen unternehmer ist trump ein
ganz schlechter verlierer
constanze stelzenmüller die
politikwissenschaftlerin stellt fest die
usa stehen vor einer echten
verfassungskrise
annalena baerbock die grünen vorsitzende
fordert auch die letzte briefwahl stimme
muss ausgezählt werden
und thomas gottschalk der moderator
erklärt für viele amerikaner ist trump
immer noch der selfmade-millionär der
das land wieder groß macht sie sind zu
gast bei maybrit illner und die begrüßte
gestern sehr herzlich egal ob
zugeschaltet oder hier in der runde
ja liebe zuschauer eines steht schon mal
fest donald trump war kein
betriebsunfall showtime in amerika die
demoskopen haben wieder versagt jetzt
sind die gerichte dran vor allem geht es
um briefwahlstimmen wir werden zum
verfassungsgericht gehen
trumps doppelstrategie stop and go da wo
er vorne liegt fordern seine anwälte den
stopp der auszählung etwa in georgia
oder pennsylvania da wo er knapp zurück
liegt will er alles neu auszählen lassen
also arizona und wisconsin in trance
wahrnehmung hatte es allen gezeigt klare
senatsmehrheit verteidigt fünf sitze im
repräsentantenhaus hinzugewonnen
beides umfrage vorsprung weggeschmolzen
mehr schwarze und hispanics haben trump
gewählt als noch vor vier jahren also
eine art gefühlter wahlsieger wir waren
auf dem weg zu gewinnen und ehrlich
gesagt wir haben auch gewonnen den usa
steht nun ein wochenlanges juristisches
hick-hack ins haus mag sein dass für
trump hier am ende die lichter ausgehen
doch seit gestern ist klar der tramp
ismus wird seinen erfinder überleben so
oder so
[Musik]
und einer der dort kam persönlich kennt
ist uns jetzt in washington zugeschaltet
ich begrüße john bolton seinen
ehemaligen sicherheitsberater einen
guten abend mit vielen dank das freut
mich dabei sein zu dürfen
die wichtigste frage die alle bewegt
momentan ist gab es betrug es gibt keine
hinweise auf wahlbetrug und es mag
vielleicht vereinzelte
unregelmässigkeiten im land gegeben
haben wie sie bei jeder wahl geschehen
aber für den präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten ist es wie er schon früh am
mittwochmorgen gesagt hat nämlich dass
ihm die wahl gestohlen worden sei und
das ist unverantwortlich und es gibt
auch tatsächlich kein beispiel dafür in
der amerikanischen geschichte
und er bewegt sich jetzt von der
politischen rhetorik hin zu dem punkt wo
er auch fälle vor gericht bringen möchte
und dafür braucht der beweise er hat
aber keine beweise deswegen werden die
fälle verworfen werden
und heute hat er schon einige klagen in
georgia und wisconsin versucht an zu
streng aber die sind schon abgewiesen
wurden es gibt also viele rhetorisches
feuerwerk bis heute gibt es keinen
einzigen hinweis darauf dass wirklich
etwas passiert ist rechnen sie boten
damit dass die klagen aus den
bundesstaaten dann am ende tatsächlich
beim supreme court landen kann
das ist schwer zu beurteilen wir müssen
erst einmal genau beobachten was die
trump kampagne da dann als klage
formuliert es ist nicht unausweichlich
dass diese fälle vor das supreme court
kommen ich bin ein veteran wenn es um
diese art von fragen geht auch bei den
auseinandersetzungen zwischen kohl und
bush 2000 dass er bis vor den supreme
court ging und da haben wir eine klare
vorstellung dessen wie das supreme court
vor geht nämlich sich anschaut wie die
wahlverfahren in den einzelnen staaten
aussehen und sie werden natürlich die
entsprechende gesetzgebung beachte
die dann eben dazu führt dass es eine
entscheidung gibt bei diesen
umstrittenen punkten und das elektro
college die wahlmänner werden auf jeden
fall an ihrem datum dann ihre wahl
abgeben ganz gleich ob diese fälle noch
anhängig im gericht sind es gibt hier
also bestimmte beschränkungen wir werden
nicht im chaos versinken es ist
natürlich unbequem und es verzögert
vieles das ist natürlich eine
unglückliche entwicklung aber wir sind
jetzt nicht am rande einer chaotischen
situation
es kann das ist auch schon viel gesagt
worden tage oder sogar noch wochen
dauern was denken sie wer wird zuerst
die geduld verlieren ich bin mir nicht
sicher dass irgendjemand die geduld wird
verlieren wird wenn die leute einfach
einmal tief durchatmen werden ihn klar
wird ihm klar werden dass man einfach
die regeln und prozeduren befolgt wie es
sie gibt natürlich gibt es auch
erfahrung schon mit sehr engen
wahlergebnis mit knappen wahlergebnissen
mit rechtlichen vorgehen
das heißt auch nicht dass wir keine
erfahrung hätten wie man damit umzugehen
hat aber ich glaube dass das system was
wir haben bestimmte garantien aufweist
nämlich auch für transparenz unter
anderem und es ist eine sache zu sagen
dass die wahlergebnisse gefälscht wären
das andere ist es das auch beweisen zu
können und ohne beweise werden diese
verfahren dann auch nichts bringen
wieder auszählung brauchen natürlich
enorm fehlzeiten wir werden schauen
welche rechtsmittel schwamb einsetzen
möchte aber es gibt bestimmte gesetzlich
vorgeschriebene verfahren in den fünfzig
verschiedenen staaten da muss nichts neu
erfunden werden
auch republikaner sie haben es erwähnt
sind erschrocken über die statements von
donald trump am dienstag musste man da
wirklich so überrascht sein
ich war selbst nicht überrascht und ich
glaube dass viele republikaner
allerdings ziemlich überrascht waren und
das ist ihnen auch unangenehm zu sehen
wie wenig dieser präsident in der lage
ist und auch wie unwillens er ist sein
eigenes interesse von dem interesse des
landes zu trennen und das ist für mich
einer der zwingenden gründe gewesen ihn
in dieser bahn nichts unter
dutzend menschen doch wieder gewählt
wird was würde dann aus amerika und was
würde aus einem republikaner wiegen
ich glaube nach den wahlen ob tram
gewinnt oder verliert werden wir ein
ernsthaft unterhaltung in unserer partei
haben müssen ich habe mit vielen
gewählten republikanischen amtsträgern
im ganzen land gesprochen und ich glaube
es ist wichtig dass alle verstehen dass
ganz gleich wie das wahlergebnis
aussehen wird donald trump kein
konservativer republikaner ist der hat
keine philosophie dieser art er hat
keine großen strategien auch nicht im
bereich der nationalen sicherheit er
versteht politik noch nicht einmal in
konventionellen sinn erst eine anomalie
er ist eine abgleichung wenn man so will
und das ist etwas was glaube ich ganz
besonders die menschen im ausland
verstehen sollte er steht nicht für die
vereinigten staaten und ganz sicher
nicht für die republikanische partei
und was wird aus ihnen nun hab ich hoffe
dass ich eine rolle spielen werden in
diesen konversationen auch wenn joe
biden gewonnen haben sollte und ein auf
sein amt eingeschworen wird dann werde
ich ab dem folgetag dann auch artikel
über ihn und seine politik schreiben
glauben sie dass donald trump freiwillig
das weiße haus verlässt ich glaube er
wird das weiße haus schon freiwillig
verlassen aber nicht besonders anständig
das ist einfach nicht in ihm angelegt
ich glaube es ist sehr theoretisch jetzt
darüber nachzudenken und dass er
versuchen würde im amt zu bleiben obwohl
vielleicht klar ist dass er die wahl
verloren hat denn unser
verfassungsmäßiges gerüst ist ein sehr
stabiles und es drängt auf eine
entscheidung hin wenn er gewinnt kann er
bleiben wenn er verliert muss er gehen
und wenn es notwendig ist dann wird das
auch der charaktertest für die
republikanische partei werden wie das
damals zu zeiten von watergate auch der
fall war
das waren republikaner die damals auf
nixon zugegangen sind und gesagt haben
du hast die unterstützung verloren und
du musst zurücktreten und es müssen dann
auch republikanische politische
führungsfiguren sein team so etwas
mitteilen so etwas nahe legen
john baut einen ganz herzlichen dank für
ihre einschätzung heute vielen dank nach
washington und einen guten tag und damit
sind wir hier in der runde an der däne
berbalk ist bei uns eine der beiden
vorsitzenden von den grünen frau
baerbock
egal wie diese wahl aussieht würden sie
sagen jump ist am ende der gewinner
robert habeck hat gesagt das geht nicht
weg man sieht ja sehr sehr deutlich auch
an diesem wahlergebnis aber man hat ja
auch schon die ganze zeit davor gesehen
wie tief das land gespalten ist auf eine
absolut erschreckende art und weise also
ich war vom guten jahr selber noch dort
und habe vor langer langer zeit auch mal
dort gelebt und das was ich immer stark
geschätzt habe an den usa aber auch dass
man so offen über politik diskutieren
konnte den wir hier lange zeit immer ein
geheimnis draus gemacht wer wählt was
und in amerika war es ja gang und gäbe
dass man ganz offen gesagt hat ich bin
republikaner ich bin demokrat und
trotzdem leidenschaftlich miteinander
diskutiert hat und dieser riss der jetzt
tief in der gesellschaft ist wenn man
dort ist dass die 1 nicht mehr mit den
anderen sprechen durch familien durch
geht das ist was wo ich sehr sehr stark
für die amerikanische gesellschaft hoffe
dass es einen weg und eine chance der
heilung gibt aber dass das nicht einfach
wird das sieht man ja auch in diesen
stunden
naja und deswegen ist es deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass die institutionen die
demokratischen institutionen jetzt ihren
job machen dass jede stimme gezählt wird
und dann auch klar ist dass ein
endergebnis fest steht damit überhaupt
eine art der heilung irgendwann einmal
in kraft treten kann
wir begrüßen in baden-baden thomas
gottschalk mit seinen zweiten wohnsitz
in kalifornien zu hause thomas vier
weitere jahre donald trump vielleicht
könnte für sie irgendwann der zeitpunkt
kommen amerika den rücken zudrehen
nein amerika ist ja nicht donald trump
und donald trump ist nicht amerika was
mich so fasziniert auch jetzt gerade an
john bolton ist die bestätigung dessen
dass die amerikaner eine gewisse
naivität eine gewisse fahrlässigkeit
haben die sie einerseits sehr
sympathisch macht andererseits also
selbst für mich einen leichtfüßigen
entertainer oft nicht nachvollziehbar
ist john bolton war ja wohl mal ein
unterstützer von trump und es gibt viele
republikaner die einfach gesagt haben
der ist uns von der leine gegangen nur
hätten die vorher erkennen müssen was
für ein mensch das ist ich habe mit
vielen republikanern gesprochen es gibt
ja da gerade nur in malibu sehr
wohlhabende menschen die sich der
politik verschrieben haben der mann
wollte botschafter in deutschland werden
und hat gesagt der tram hat in so vielen
dingen recht aber er ist so so in seiner
in seiner formulierung dieser argumente
ist er so grottenschlecht also der mann
hatte recht haben die gesagt aber wir
haben dem schon im griff es zeigt sich
eben jetzt dass sie ihn nicht im griff
gehabt
die republikaner sind von kramp
enttäuscht und ich glaube das spricht
für sie da spricht für das politische
system in amerika dass ich nicht
erklären kann aber ich kann denen
vielleicht ein bisschen den deutschen
dieser amerikanische mentalität näher
bringen die wir alle falsch einschätzen
wir haben eine wunschvorstellung der
amerikaner der kommen sie aber leider
nicht nach dort haben sie haben es
angesprochen gilt als guter internet
sind sie denn wenigstens eine art
kollegen
das ist ja das furchtbare das ich ist ja
nie waren würde in die politik zu gehen
aber trump ist einem entertainer so
ähnlich man erkennt in seinem agieren
entertainer elemente nur er ist im
gegensatz zu mir ein reality star
man merkt dass er sich aus seiner rolle
bei airprint ist wo er im grunde ein
bezahlter reality darsteller war der die
bösartigkeit die ihm offensichtlich inne
ist
entertainment mäßig präsentieren konnte
das taugt zum fernsehen das taugt für
eine reality show das taugt glaube ich
nicht für politik von der millionen
menschen abhängig sind
wir begrüßen martin richenhagen bei uns
sie sind deutscher mit us amerikanischer
staatsbürgerschaft das heißt sie durften
wählen herrig nagen
und sie führen ein unternehmen als
einziger deutscher das zu den top 500 in
den usa gehört frage an den
erfolgreichen unternehmer was würden
vier weitere jahre donald trump peter ja
vier jahren ähnliche politik die
amerikaner sagen for years of the same
und der performance artist würde
wahrscheinlich noch etwas emotionaler
agieren weil er natürlich nicht mehr
angewiesen wäre auf eine wiederwahl es
könnte also ein bisschen exotischer
werden oder noch schlimmer werden
david will ist bei uns vize-direktorin
des german marshall fund hier in berlin
was hat sie frau david will mehr
überrascht der sieg von donald trump
oder das schwache abschneiden der
demokraten ist reicht ihr nicht mal für
senat uns repräsentieren beitrag gehabt
ich da aber die umfrage waren wieder
sehr in vielen genau wie in 2010
man dachte dass am joe biden auch siege
im preisen bundesstaaten wie in texas
vorder- oder auch texas florida und
reihe kriegen wurde und das war nicht
einfach und man hat auch gesagt es gab
viele chance im senat man hat viel geld
ausgegeben
in bundesstaaten wie mähen und auch in
south carolina aber dort haben die
republikaner gewonnen aber trotzdem ich
glaube momentan sieht es gut aus für joe
biden
es wird ein knapper sieg sein aber wir
werden am ende ein kandidat haben und er
hat die meisten stimmen schon erreicht
aller zeiten und daher wenn er die 270
war männer kriegen dann hatte eine
starke mandat und es könnte auch sein
dass er rote bundesstaaten erobert wie
georgia und muss man einfach abwarten
wir haben einen bei uns in der sinn
der ist richtig findet dass donald trump
jetzt die gerichte anruf bei uns ist
benjamin wolf meyer der pressesprecher
von republicans overseas warum denken
sie dass das richtig ist was glauben sie
werden die feststellen die gerichte im
gegensatz zu der berichterstattung die
jetzt nicht nur bei ihnen war zu dem
thema sondern in den ganzen deutschen
medien ist es nicht so dass donald trump
die auszählung von stimmen stoppen will
uns geht es darum juristisch klären zu
lassen ob es wirklich sein können dass
wahlzettel die nachwahl nach schließung
der wahllokale noch ein treffen manchmal
von irgendwo her was noch nicht mal
nachvollziehbar ist ob das richtig sein
kann wir finden das falsch
wir möchten das juristisch geklärt haben
ich finde auch dass eigentlich jeder der
demokratisch eingestellt ist sich diese
frage stellen muss und da nichts gegen
haben kann aber es geht auch noch um
zwei drei andere punkte also es wurde zb
invest konz in ist der verdacht da das
in mehreren counties mehr leute gewählt
haben als es registrierte wähler gibt es
wurden indes konnten kleine moment ich
würde das gerne ausführen weil das ist
glaube ich für den deutschen zuschauer
auch wirklich wichtig doch auch erfahren
dass das was sie sagen ach ja falsch
lassen sie mich doch erstmal auswählen
dann können sie gerne erwidern
es sind mehrere wahlleute von unserer
seite die bei den auszählungen dabei war
wo sein wollten gehindert worden in
wisconsin in michigan in pennsylvania
und libera 3 in spanien bitte nun sind
sie doch dabei in wisconsin
es ist doch schon ein bei der auszählung
ja gibt es mehrere belege dass leute von
uns wirklich von den demokraten aus dem
raum rausgeschmissen wurden dass es
inakzeptabel für uns das werden wir uns
nicht gefallen lassen dass auch das
läuft ja vor gericht und es wird
sicherlich ein bis konsum michigan
neuauszählungen geben per hand und das
warten wir doch alles mal in ruhe ab und
am ende entscheiden dann vielleicht die
gerichte aber auch das finde ich jetzt
keine schlimme sache ich finde auch das
es muss an der demokratie möglich sein
und 2000 hat ja auch gezeigt dass das
auch funktionieren kann so und dass sich
jemand aber bevor das ergebnis
festgestellt selbst zum wahlsieger
klärt herbert meyer das kennt man sonst
eigentlich nur aus afrika oder aus
südamerika oder aus belarus also wenn
dann könnte man ja auch sagen joe biden
hat sich ja vorher noch erklärt bevor
dann entfernt sich das erste mal erklärt
hat das war ja auch schon wie so ein
reclam ich habe gewonnen
ich habe dass er so stimmt nicht ich hab
ich habe gesagt das habe ich so
empfunden ja es ist das können sie sehr
wohl nicht absprechen was ich habe finde
es wäre ja noch schöner
also ich habe das von donald trump er so
verstanden dass er die staaten meinte wo
er vorne liegt also pennsylvania north
carolina georgia dass er die gewonnen
hat das sehe ich übrigens auch so aber
nicht dass die wahl an sich schon
entschieden ist das ist noch offen er
einer von uns weiß wer am ende die wahl
gewonnen hat und wir mehr bundesstaaten
gerade arizona weiß das glaube ich
wirklich niemand und kann das auch
niemand vorhersagen wie das ausgeht so
und das ist auch ein bisschen
widersprüchlich ist dass sie in manchen
staaten nach der ersten halbzeit stoppen
wollen weil sie schon gesiegt haben und
dass sie in anderen staaten für eine
nachspielzeit plädieren weil sie noch
nicht vorne liegen
das gibt es nicht mehr im fußball das
ist falsch das tun wir nicht wir sagen
nur bestimmte stimmzettel die halt nach
schließung der wahllokale möchte noch
einmal betonen dass die nicht zählen
sollen allerdings und das ist dann egal
welcher bundesstaat ob wir da vorne
liegen oder hinten legen spielt dabei
keine rolle
es geht einfach um dieses verfahren was
die demokraten übrigens das möchte dann
auch noch mal sagen fünf monate vor der
wahl haben die demokraten die
spielregeln für die briefwahl verändert
zu ihren gunsten und auch nur in sechs
ringsted wo sie die gouverneure stellen
und das alleine finden schon ein sehr
ungewohnt unklar und dann kann es herrn
richenhagen kommen noch auf dem stuhl
halten die demokraten haben uns die wahl
gestohlen
es sagt die tram fraktion geht es
überhaupt das geht natürlich nicht und
ich bin ganz verwundert dass wir einen
gast haben der nicht amerikaner ist der
nicht in amerika lebt und da hier die
großen sprüche markt das finde ich
unakzeptabel
ich bitte auch diesen jungen mann darum
sich an der wahrheit zu orientieren das
macht schon der präsident nicht dann
müssen das aber die jungen republikaner
vielleicht ein bisschen besser macht
ich finde das unangenehm und unanständig
weil sie sagen jede stimme die gültig
ist und die abgegeben wurde muss gezielt
wert genau das war ganz normaler
demokratischer prozess in jeder
funktionierenden demokratie dieser welt
und die ganzen stories die ja diese
ganzen stories die ja da erzählt das
alles blödsinn ja auch die demokraten
haben eine armee von anwälten in
stellung gebracht misstrauen auch die
demokraten in diesem amerikanischen
wahlsystem überhaupt nicht und ich
glaube die meisten amerikaner vor
download shop haben geglaubt an unsere
demokratie
zum ersten mal haben wir ein präsident
der zweifelt an uns dass das unsere
demokratische system nicht funktioniert
und das ist das ist sehr schade
die demokraten waren einfach vorbereitet
war präsident hat immer bedeutet das
wenn er verliert dann gibt's wahlbetrug
aber der fch hat auch gesagt es gibt
kein beweis für systematisches
wahlbetrug in den usa und die osze hat
das auch gesagt wir begrüßen die jetzt
an dieser stelle
constanze stelzenmüller vom thinktank
brookings die und zugeschaltet ist aus
washington
frage an sie frau stelzenmüller im
grunde muss man doch sagen wenn jemand
zweifel an einem wahlergebnis hat kann
er vor gericht gehen warum ist das dann
schon eine verfassungskrise die
verfassungskrise würde ich auch anders
definiert ich finde die besteht darin
dass der präsident eigentlich jeden tag
seit seinem amtsantritt die grund normen
und regeln der amerikanischen
repräsentativen demokratie die auf die
eine oder andere weise infrage gestellt
hat nicht zuletzt die gewaltenteilung
aber in diesem fall muss man sagen oder
diesem fall würde ich sagen dass ihm
unbenommen mit seinen anfechtungen vor
gericht zu gehen aber es ist in der tat
auffällig dass die ersten gerichte den
bezeichnenden klagen beschafft worden
sind die wegen offensichtlichen
ungenügendes abgewiesen haben und das ja
auch republikaner rief erbauten das in
zweifel ziehen dass das als taktik
funktionieren
sie würde aber sagen jede gültige stimme
die abgegeben wurde muss gezählt werden
klar habe ich sie nicht nachträglich
stimmen die von irgendwoher teilweise
auf tauchen plötzlich das nicht es gab
dem wahltag es gab eineinhalb monate
zeit briefwahl oder early warning zu
machen und dann gab es den wahltag punkt
aus und die wahllokale hatten
geschlossen
damit ist das verfahren dann
abgeschlossen und dann muss aber eben
auch gezählt werden
wir sind bei frau baerbock
donald trump hat dieses system vblock
nicht erfunden
und dann ist er vielleicht der erste
politiker der diese vielen dinge die man
hinterfragen kann und die ist wirklich
kompliziert machen
der ist so konsequent ausnutzte ja seit
gestern oder seit vorgestern sondern wie
einige andere jetzt ja vorher auch schon
gesagt haben eigentlich seit dem tag
seines ersten amtsantritt hass hat er ja
auf systematische art und weise versucht
demokratische strukturen anzugreifen die
ganzen kampagnen mit lügen menschen zu
diskreditieren und die vorstellung ich
glaube das ist wichtig für uns in europa
als europäer aus dieser wahl zu zu
lernen auch auswahlen die wir ja in
europa schon hatten auch populisten wo
viele dann gesagt haben
daher sollen die erstmals am kommen und
dann werden die sich schon ein finden
wird alles halb so schlimm werden oder
berater werden sie einhegen das war ja
auch die große hoffnung auch herr boden
muss mir auch sehr deutlich sagen hat
hat am anfang im jahr massiv unterstützt
auch was herr gottschalk gesagt hat 6
erhältlich und ich glaube das ist es
wichtige momentum das wir gemeinsam als
demokraten weltweit begreifen
nein solche leute die eben demokratische
strukturen vorher angreifen wollen die
setzen das in der tat um es wird
schlimmer werden weil natürlich solche
angriffe dann auch verfangen weil
minderheiten unterdrückt werden weil
menschen ihre rechte genommen werden und
das muss die große lehre sein und aus
meiner sicht auch die große leere
dann mit blick auf republikaner ja die
frage wie konnte man eigentlich zu dem
zeitpunkt als die republikaner nominiert
haben herrn trump nochmal in der art und
weise wieder nominiert
wissentlich was er alles dieser
großartigen demokratie schon angetan
hatte bis zu dem das heim getan hat
deswegen haben wir ihn wieder keiner
gemerkt auch doch das haben aber die
villa anders gesehen würde ich mal ist
so dann sind wir gleich aber bei der
entscheidenden frage wer waren die
wähler von donald trump ich würde mit
thomas gottschalk mal anfangen wollen
sie haben schon erzählt sie kennen
natürlich republikanische wähler waren
auch welche dabei über die sie sich
gewundert haben warum sind eben sie auch
hispanics warum haben schwarze zum
zweiten mal damals stand gewährt also
erstmal muss man feststellen dass die
amerikaner ein anderes verhältnis zur
politik haben als wir
government ist etwas was mit ihrem
alltäglichen leben wenig zu tun hat wir
deutsche sagen was die
gesundheitspolitik was die kulturpolitik
betrifft das ist alles sache der
regierung des staates das sehen die
amerikaner überhaupt nicht so und was
was das enttäuschende eben ist ist auch
das niveau auf dem la gearbeitet wird
ich hatte das große glück oder das
zweifelhafte glück die wahlwerbung der
republikaner und der demokraten zu
kriegen also trump hat jetzt gerade vor
10 minuten hier eine geschickt freund
ein need you will have to try to steal
des elektro ein calling you to step and
fight back to support ist critical right
now
da gab es keine politischen argumente
das waren im grunde aufrufe jetzt forsch
in den kampf zu marschieren gegen das
unrecht von beiden seiten ich bin
entsetzt dass eine figur wie trump
letzten endes die größte nation der welt
quasi vertreten soll wir haben ja alle
gelernt in den letzten jahren dass
politik immer komplexer wird immer
schwer zu immer schwerer zu vermitteln
trump ist kein mensch der komplex ist
intellektuell begreift um es dann zu
vermitteln
obama war ein intellektueller obama war
ein philosoph vor dem herrn
beiden ist auch ein rechtschaffener
freundliche alte herr dem ich das
genauso wenig zutrauen
also wenn das die spitze der
amerikanisch
politik sein soll die man uns da
präsentiert dann gute nacht es gibt
andere aber wo sind die geblieben auf
dem weg zur präsidentschaftswahl über
beiden werden wir gerne noch reden und
tun das auf jeden fall noch frau der
große frage sind natürlich tatsächlich
die hispanics latinos werden sie hier
komischerweise genannt also er ist
einiges und auch die schwarzen rassismus
und auch soziale ungerechtigkeit hat
nicht für die demokraten eingezahlt
kommt dass ich glaube das war doch ein
wichtiges thema aber für alle amerikaner
spielt natürlich die wirtschaft eines
der eine sehr starke rolle und donald
trumps messaging aber sehr effektiv er
hat gezeigt oder er hat dargestellt
joe biden aus dass akten kandidat und er
hat auch die demokraten aus linke
radikale nock abend dargestellt und er
selbst wiederum hat sich als kandidat
der eine bessere wirtschaft machen kann
und auch ein kandidat von braun oder und
das war sehr effektiv und man muss auch
wissen dass in 2016
er war sehr clever er hat themen
angesprochen dass beide etablierte
parteien lange ignoriert haben
die endlosen kriegen eine angebrochene
als einwanderungssystem und das war
wichtig er hat diese sachen erwähnt und
ich glaube die leute haben gesagt okay
wir geben ihnen eine chance weil die
bahre parteien arbeiten nicht für uns
auch die frage von frey welthandel die
über die köpfe von der mittelschicht
hinweg geht und ich denke alle diese
sachen am waren sehr wichtig damals und
2006 sind aber jetzt nach einer pandemie
mit große missmanagement ich bin sehr
überrascht dass es so knapp ist heute
mit der wahlliste noch nicht und er hat
immer noch eine chance zu gewinnen
natürlich obwohl wir so viel
arbeitslosigkeit und armut jetzt haben
aber bei seinen college mend von der
pandemie ist sein amt nicht dass es mit
meiner flughafens können wir gerne noch
das sieht vielleicht auch mal sie würden
sagen donald trump hat aus ihrer sicht
vielleicht viel unsinn erzählt aber
wenig unsinn gemacht was war sein
wichtigster erfolg also ich finde auch
nicht dass er jetzt so wahnsinnig für
unsinn erzählt aber gut sein wichtigster
erfolg war natürlich die wirtschaft er
hat nach der schwächsten erholung nach
einer rezession die obama beiden ja
geerbt hatten von bosch wirklich die
wirtschaft auf vordermann gebracht und 7
millionen neue arbeitsplätze geschaffen
niedrig arbeitslosigkeit seit 51 jahren
und bei sport1 panic übrigens die besten
zahlen die es jemals gab die jemals
gemessen wurden dazu eine justizreform
die vor allem minderheiten zu gute kam
oder kommt und auch gerade für die
schwarzen zum beispiel die gelder für
die unis erhöht und festgelegt so dass
die nicht zum spielball der beiden
parteien im haus werden für schwarze
communitys in städten die aktie mich am
boden wirtschaftlich liegen programme
aufgestellt für die schwarzen und für
dieses bennings halt wirklich viel getan
und das zahlt sich dann natürlich auch
aus das sieht man dann in den
wahlergebnissen wenn so viele frauen
frau baerbock wenn so viele schwarze
wenn so viele intellektuelle wenn so
viele hispanics so unterschiedliche
menschen donald trump wählen dann kann
er irgendwie nicht nur der held der
alten weißen männer seien oder waren
offensichtlich nicht weil dann wäre das
wahlergebnis sehr viel schneller sehr
viel klar gewesen und auch das ist ja
was was wir auch hier in europa auch in
unserem land ja dass man mit einfachen
antworten auch mit blick auf die frage
wie geht man gegen populismus vorgehen
wie geht man auch gegen
rechtsextremismus vor nicht einfach mit
einfachen antworten daherkommt die
menschen haben es einfach nicht
verstanden oder sie sind abgehängt und
deswegen während sie so und deswegen
muss man sich glaube ich in den usa aber
wir uns dann hier genauso
es geht ja nicht nur um die usa
irgendwie von außen zu belehren aber
sehr genau anzugucken dass es sehr
unterschiedliche gruppen sind natürlich
haben wir da eine sehr
extremistische form also auch dass ich
finde das dürfte auch in diesen momenten
nicht verschweigen ja mit blick auf die
blätter bewegung und blick was auf
rechtsextreme ausschreitungen ist
gegeben hat aber es gibt eben auch
menschen die sagen ja wir haben sorge
dass durch veränderung das hat mir schon
bei der rast diskussion was ist mit
unseren arbeitsplätzen und die fragen
was die menschen umtreibt wenn große
veränderungen anstehen dass das von
politik adressiert werden muss dass auch
in einem wahlkampf auch vorher in den
jahren von den demokraten adressiert
werden muss was ist mit bildung was es
mit dem gesundheitssystem und man sich
nicht nur ein tramp dann ab arbeitet
sondern selber antworten auf die heutige
zeit geben muss und gerade die sorgen
auch in einer globalisierten welt dass
er china angesprochen hat ja ein thema
was viele viele menschen in den usa
bewegt hat und deswegen ist es glaube
ich auch so zentral dass wir jetzt nicht
mit dem finger auf die usa zeigen
sondern uns fragen hier gerade in der
deutschen politik auch wie können wir
menschen in allen unterschiedlichen
facetten in der republik wirklich
erreichen mit der komplexität die da ist
ja also es heißt ja nicht jetzt in
schwarz-weiß reden zu verfallen sondern
komplexe fragen wirklich deutlich und
einfach auch mit den menschen zu
diskutieren ja nicht nur in deutschland
sie haben europa schon angesprochen auch
in europa gibt es kulturkämpfe und
richtig tiefe auseinandersetzung frau
david nikki haley ist frank
unterstützerinnen und ist wie sie kind
indischer einwanderer sehen wir hier in
europa einfach falsch oder unangemessen
auf den rassismus in den usa auf eine
solche bewegung wie black box mit dabei
es war ein natürlich ein großes thema in
den usa wer hat gesagt dass die mehrheit
von amerikaner werden denken das blatt
weiter
ein mainstream bewegung erst mal george
freut gibt es viele unterstützung an
anerkennung von systematisches rassismus
in den usa aber mal die demokraten
müssen auch aufpassen zu viel auf die
identität politik mit diesem thema
reinzugehen und politik und deshalb
ich bin am was eigentlich joe biden ist
ein motorrad und er ist eigentlich ein
mann für diesen moment in mein land wo
es gibt unheimlich viele polarisierung
er hat wirklich die fähigkeiten diese
sparten über zu brocken
und ja klar ich meine donald trump hat
auch indische amerikaner wäre ich habe
manchmal meine filme ja auch und erhalt
manche sagen geliefert wie
steuererleichterungen und auch
konservative richter aber die bekommt
kanisch quartal sollte sich auch fragen
wo stellt unser parteien dazu kommt
wollen wir bekannt sein idevice muss
populismus und auch
verschwörungstheorien
das finde ich nicht eine kluge strategie
für die zukunft und sollten erst
angesprochen
wohin genau herr richenhagen wichtiges
argument von herrn wolf meyer war die
wirtschaft waren diese vier jahre unter
donald trump für unternehmer von schaden
nein wir haben uns trotz trump
eigentlich ganz prächtig entwickeln kann
das hängt wir haben uns trotzdem
prächtig entwickelt der trump hat uns
nicht besonders gestört es gibt
verschiedene dinge die er ganz schlecht
gemacht hat die steuerreform war positiv
für die wirtschaft vor allen dingen die
sogenannte rückführung der im ausland
bereits versteuerten gewinne hat dazu
geführt das unternehmen aktien
zurückgekauft haben das haben wir
gemacht zum beispiel oder dividenden
gezahlt haben oder in usa investiert
haben das hat der amerikanischen
wirtschaft geholfen nicht trump hat
arbeitskräfte geschaffen sondern die
wirtschaft weil wir uns sehr bemüht
haben und ich glaube dass der tramp
große fehler gemacht hat also in den in
dem handelskrieg mit china hat er vor
allen dingen meine kunden massiv
geschädigt er war ein schlechter
schachspieler und konnte nicht
vorhersehen wie die chinesen jetzt den
nächsten zug führen die chinesen haben
sofort reagiert nach den sanktionen und
haben aufgehört in amerika sojabohnen
corn mais
hühnchenfleisch und schweinefleisch zu
kaufen im volumen von 45 bis 50
milliarden dollar pro jahr
das hat meine kunden zutiefst geschädigt
und mein geschäft in amerika ist 30
prozent also landmaschinen massey
ferguson fendt 30 prozent runter
gegangen
auch die anderen industrien was er
gemacht hat er hat der öl industrie
geholfen und dem bergbau aber zu lasten
der umwelt das dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen das ist ja keine nachhaltige
politik die er da gemacht hat und das
ist auch so falsch unternehmer haben
sich auch öffentlich empört über donald
trump aber sie haben schon angesprochen
die steuersenkung man gerne mitgenommen
neuerungen sind immer gut auch
gottschalk und für mich das werden wir
toll
das heißt also sie würden sich auch
darüber freuen
wir freuen uns auch darüber dass hat
trump auch angepackt wenn der staat
effizienter ist und wenn der staat mit
weniger personal arbeitet aber wenn sie
heute nach washington fahren da weiß ja
keiner mehr wer für was verantwortlich
ist das ist eine katastrophe das kann
man sich gar nicht so vorstellen
der obama hat da ein bestelltes haus
hinterlassen da kann man darüber
nachdenken wie man will und dann kommt
dazu dieser seltsame mensch ich habe ja
selbst keine haare unter gottschalk ist
ein experte im design
aber wenn man so rumläuft da muss man
sich doch die frage stand hatte keine
familie die nicht mehr passt mal auf
junge so kannst du nicht raus gehen ich
kenne sein schneider ich habe denselben
schneider wie vitra und das ist ein
libanese dann sage ich ali kannst du
nicht mal mit dem reden muss doch du
musst dir doch mal beraten dann hat er
gesagt nee das geht nicht er hört nicht
auf mich also trump hört nicht zu er ist
mit dem auf der ds auf der kollege ist
und im wahlkampf hat gesagt so jetzt
haben wir mal die krawatte richtig in
der länge dann ist der tramp auf die
toilette gegangen und hatte wieder nach
unten durch hängen lassen trampert
zugenommen massiv will das aber nicht
wahrhaben wenn da maß angelegt wird
korrigierte die zahlen
also das ist ein ganz seltsam an und er
gehört einfach nicht an die spitze
irgendeines landes oder auch irgend
einer großen firma
er kann seinen immobilien kram machen
aber sonst hat er nichts drauf wirklich
nicht ich habe ihn mehrfach getroffen
ich kann das buch das so und sie haben
ihnen vor vier jahren gewählt da ein
gerücht also ich habe nicht trump
gewählt sondern ich habe ich habe rein
eingetragen also so ähnlich wie wollten
haben namen eingetragen
trump habe ich nicht gehört weil ich ja
vorher schon mal kennengelernt habe in
pittsburgh auf dem flughafen das war
ganz lustig kann man mit seinem riesen
teil da angefroren wir haben einen
schönen firmenjet also wir müssen uns
nicht beklagen packte neben jahren hat
jet und dann hat er mich da reingeführt
und dann hingen an diesen dingen das war
so mit rotem purpur und samt und gold
ausgestattet öl gemälde an der wand von
denen er dachte sich seien echt experte
nahm da teilweise andere meinungen der
vater ob ich impressed sei dann habe ich
gesagt nord reli und dann war ein
bisschen erstaunt und dann habe ich
gesagt na ja haben sie dann in ihrem suv
auch ölgemälde hängen also dass hier für
mich ein transport transport werkzeug
zur belohnung habe ich dann aber
bekommen eine große dose haarspray und
er hat mir erklärt wie er das mit seiner
frisur macht hat mit einer anleitung
gegeben
die habe ich leider damit fahrer noch
nicht präsident weggeschmissen
und da hat er gesagt das wirkt wie
glasfasern also der mann hat eine andere
waffe das hab ich jemals so sagen